[Música]
tengo varios días tratando de
comunicarme con María
y esta mañana
decidí visitarla
cuando las puertas del tren se abrieron
me sentía súper emocionada porque le iba
a contar a María que el libro con su
historia ya estaba listo
cuando llegue la portera estaba
limpiando la vereda nos saludamos y me
dijo que María había fallecido
no la mente profundamente
realmente no me lo esperaba no me lo
esperaba
escribir una nota para el Hijo de María
que en parte decía
tengo algo que le pertenecía a tu mamá
ahora es tuyo
ese mismo día se comunico conmigo y
quedamos de vernos en un café
cuando le muestre el libro que habíamos
escrito juntas lo primero que Carlos
hizo fue detenerse en el título y la
foto de su mamá
leyó varias páginas estuvimos charlando
como por una hora
Carlos estaba sorprendido
tenía los ojos brillantes y con una
sonrisa de esas que salen de lo más
profundo de esas sonrisas que no se
pueden ocultar o evitar y me dijo
tuning
es como si estuviera escuchando a mamá
es que el libro es desde ahora el tesoro
más valioso que pueda tener
yo soy una mujer migrante mamá de
sunimar sulimar y suguimar de profesión
docente
salí de mi país Venezuela en el 2016 con
la maleta rota me sentía vulnerable
lo había dejado todo atrás
triste estaba desesperada
necesitaba trabajar tenía que trabajar
en mi país fui directora de una red de
escuela así que para mí lo ideal era
conseguir un empleo como maestra en una
escuela y logre desempeñarme en una
escuela pero como personal de limpieza
también fui trabajadora de casa
particular y acompañante de personas
mayores en geriátricos y cama dentro
así conocí a María cuando la conocí
tenía 91 años y decía que había vivido
33215 días cada uno guardado fielmente
en su memoria tenía la voz suave y dulce
era delgada tenía la piel blanca y unos
ojos hermosos azules le encantaba
conversar y vivía sola
estuvimos juntas por seis meses nunca
antes había hablado tanto con una
persona de esa edad me impresionaba su
lucidez y admiraba su memoria cuando
María hablaba de sus hijos y de sus
nietas el rostro se iluminaba me contaba
lo que había vivido
la época de los militares su trabajo
como voluntaria en Casa Cuna sus
alegrías y sus tristezas
tú recuerdos no se parecían a los míos
pero igual que los míos habían
permanecido en silencio frente a una
persona extraña frente a una desconocida
yo nací en el campo rodeada de personas
adultas
cultivos y cría de animales
el camino era de tierra oscuro y
culebrero vivíamos en el rancho de una
hacienda a orillas del río Limón
la corriente era tan fuerte que se
llevaba todo a su paso
dormíamos en hamaca mami Rocío a gasoil
alrededor del rancho para evitar que
entraran las culebras
fueron tiempos muy difíciles
duros
tres y
sin escuchar mi voz
pensando que no tenía nada interesante
que decir que nadie me escuchaba y que
no estaba para los demás pero eso cambio
cuando nacieron mis hijas con mis amigas
en la escuela y en la universidad
descubrí que mi voz si era escuchada
por eso sentí esta profunda empatía con
María lo que era importante para ella el
ser escuchada también lo era para mí y
en lo que me contaba lo extraordinario
que había en lo cotidiano esas cosas que
parecen simples o pequeñas pero que son
la vida misma
María hablaba con tanto entusiasmo de su
vivencia y acariciar en mis pensamientos
la idea de escribir por eso le pregunté
que le parece si escribimos lo que me
cuenta
te animas me dijo
gracias rato que yo estaba animada
describir que solo me centre en poner
mis manos a la obra
así que para mañana teníamos largas
charlas en la mesa del desayuno
educación es María hacía una pausa
miraba por la ventana y suspiraba y me
decía es un suspiro de nostalgia sonido
extraño mi vida
extraño a los que ya no están y extraño
lo que hacía
qué con mi teléfono yo la grababa tomaba
algunos apuntes lo que decía y también
de sus expresiones y mientras ella hacía
la siesta y otra escribía
se despertaba curiosa por ver lo que
había escrito y lo leía en voz alta
desde la lacto
se quebrantaba su voz y a veces lágrima
va porque llora le pregunté
me dijo
escribiste tú ni es de emoción jamás
pensé que alguien se tomaría el tiempo
para escribir sobre mi vida y es que sus
recuerdos fluyan como un río fresco y
transparente me decía una y otra vez
esto que te estoy contando es desde mi
corazón ese fue el título del libro y el
primero que escribí
hasta ese momento yo no me había
detenido a pensar en esa necesidad que
tenemos de comunicarnos atrás vivencia y
en este poder
sabor y efecto que tienen las palabras
de quién las dice pero también le quién
las recibe para María hablar de sus
vivencias hija cómo tomarse una bebida
energizante se reía a carcajadas lloraba
suspiraba y extrañaba
mira cómo recuperar con las palabras la
fuerza de cada etapa vivida
y para el disco
el libro de mamá el tesoro más valioso
que pueda tener
y para las nietas y bisnieta la historia
de agua en un libro les da la
oportunidad de conocer un poco más sobre
ella y como decía María es una delicia
para mí hablar con mi nieta ahora es una
delicia para las nietas en el libro con
la historia de María en sus manos
y el efecto que tuvo en mí escuchar a
María fue inesperado sanador inspirador
empecé a plantearme algunas preguntas me
encontraba respuesta porque al principio
no podía entender como una persona de 91
años a pesar de las diferentes
situaciones difíciles que le tocó vivir
podía hablar con tanta fluidez de su
vivencia
desde entonces sigue escribiendo sobre
la vida en las personas mayores
y la fórmula es muy sencilla
escribir con el corazón y la mente
abierta pero apagando todo juicio de
valor esto despertó algo que ya no se
volvió a dormir y empecé a contar mi
historia junto a otras historias
ahora puedo recorrer mi infancia
eligiendo otro recuerdos veo a la niña
que fui correr con los pies descalzos y
el cabello despeinado
escucho la corriente del trío cuando
pasa entre las piedras
escucha el manduco que golpea la ropa
para lavarla en el río
escucho la lluvia cayendo sobre la
tierra
y repiqueteando sobre el techo de
escucho y me escucho pude entender a la
niña la adolescencia
y a la esposa que fui porque siempre
hice lo que la circunstancia me
permitieron lo mismo me paso cuando
escuché y escribir la historia de mi
madre comprendí que mami hizo justo lo
que pudo
estos libros no los hago sola somos un
equipo de 6 mujeres latinoamericanas de
Venezuela Colombia y Argentina
[Aplausos]
cada una con su conocimiento y habilidad
nosotras hacemos todo desde las
entrevistas transcripción revisión
elección de foto el proceso de maquetar
y la encuadernación artesanal nuestro
desafío en cada libro que escribimos es
mantener la oralidad del narrador y no
se escucha mi voz sino la suya
frente al silencio de tantas vidas estos
libros son palabras sonoras
me encantó esa alianza que nació entre
María y yo y agradezco haberla conocido
porque me inspiró para escribir sobre
esos recuerdos que hacen ruido en el
silencio
soy lo que escribo tocando la
sensibilidad del otro como han tocado la
mía
el miedo al ocaso es un sentimiento que
a todos nos toca por eso me emociona
seguir encontrando historias que pueden
ser contadas y guardadas amorosamente en
la memoria familiar
cada libro es la huella digital de una
vida que podrá ser elegida y recordada
de una generación a otra más allá del
tiempo
[Música]